I just got to the airport I'm in line
for security now and there's a massive
line I'm not sure I'll make it I don't
really know why we're going to Dubai I
mean the official reason is that the big
drone competition in Dubai is this
weekend we had this really really cool
Star Wars idea involving these racing
drones I don't know where we're going
our flight was originally at 2:30 I got
delayed build 3 3:30 no kinda just got
the late so for will we ever get to
Dubai waiting on a text from Luke and
there it is but let's see if we can find
it in here hey guess what we're going do
bot like Ryan I didn't know we were
getting beer so gonna be with you hello
my name is Brian I'm an Irish man and
I'm going to show you as stereotypes are
born like video Luke told us like hey
you want to go to Dubai and was like
sure in the entire week and I was like I
don't know I'm not gonna get my hopes up
I'm just gonna believe it's not gonna
happen so I don't get disappointed I was
very positive and about it and then by
yesterday running and then like last
night at 7 I get an email from Luke
saying looks like it's actually
happening and even after that we didn't
get confirmation until this morning and
say that we got like on the same hey fun
red hey we're about to take off
we're literally out on the runway
I just went around the entire airport
sure enough they come onto the intercom
saying there's a bit of a malfunction
just before lift up hopefully we'll be
able to take off at all we should have
taken off three hours ago
removing
oh hey guys happy to see you welcome to
the box get our bags then we need to go
through immigration and then we had to
find this invisible driver only it's a
stretch Hummer limousine Russia no truck
yeah
if we get a hundred thousand thumbs up
we'll post photos of random bikinis I
can't do Heights I have to get the shot